I love farmer gets a release date Sega
has a big announcement for something
itty-bitty and the bunch of stuff is
getting delayed I'm Curt and welcome to
safe state for June 30 Wednesday
pokemon sword and shield Isle of armors
is coming out on June 17th now we
already knew we were getting a new
legendary Pokemon earthy foo in Giganta
max forms for both sword and shield
starters but we're also getting gigantic
max forms for Blastoise and venusaur we
also got a look at glaring sloper and a
new device called cram all medic you
feed it for items and the spits out a
new one which could be rare in the midst
of all these new announcements Sega's
got one but for something old they're
launching the game gear micro and it's
coming to Japan this October and when
its micro I mean it's micro it is like
super tiny 80 millimeters by 43
millimeters this is this is roughly if
my calculations are correct this is it
this is this is what we're gonna be
seeing in October it's coming in four
colors and it's so small that they're
gonna have a clip-on magnifier screen
for the thing each color plays a
different set of games and it will cost
4000 and 980 yen which translates to
about $45 now the blue one is the most
important one because it comes with gun
star heroes which is one of the greatest
games ever made hmm
I think this this could work you know
what they say about micro hands Micro
game gears earlier this week Sony
delayed its PlayStation 5 event and well
it looks like that's the first of a lot
of things that are gonna be delayed so
we got cyberpunk 2020 s 9th city wire
was scheduled for June 11th but now it's
being pushed to June 25th
CD Projekt RED says quote more important
discussions are happening right now and
we want them to be heard in quote call
duty season 4 in Mobile season 7 would
be out today but it's pushed back to
later dates call duty on Twitter said a
quote right now it's time for those
speaking up for equality justice and
change to be seen and heard we stand a
sideyou in quote men and 21 head news
plan for June 8th but that was delayed
fortnight's next icon skin has been
delayed now while all this stuff is
being delayed the last last of us part 2
in depth gameplay trailer did come out
today still so check that out we have it
on our channel we'll have some stuff
about it yeah also don't forget GameSpot
is doing play for all a multi-week
charity event where every single day
we're gonna be having a charity stream
from 12 p.m. to 2 p.m. Pt featuring a
whole load of guests to raise money for
both people fighting against cope at 19
and also black lives matter
so tomorrow Thursday June 4th we're
gonna have been from mid max Jake from
gamer ranks Brandon from easy allies and
blessing from kind of funny and they're
gonna be doing a trivia game challenge
thing then on Friday we're gonna have
hey Zeus here's toast doing a
blood-borne speedrun but there's
something happening every single day so
check out the link in the description
below to see the full schedule for
things to come we're also going to be
having exclusive content with games
coming alongside the charity events so
be on the lookout for that
alright that's it for today's safe State
but of course there's that and a whole
bunch more at gamespot.com so be sure to
check that out
I'm Curtin Davina that's all I got yeah
be well be cool be safe come back
tomorrow okay
why do that